merci revois tes petites têtes
aujourd'hui par comme un avis non non
non pas la seule
c'est moi voilà et chacun à son tour son
arc elle perçoit son arc dans la saison
et non chaque épisode souvent fait le
plus souvent les secondaires souvent
phoebe ou donc jo et une action plus là
pour les vannes
oui très bien
messieurs vous disposez très exactement
2 5 secondes pour sauver la terre écoute
aristide j'aime beaucoup c'est pas la
question
on a passé de très bons moments toi et
moi mais ça marchera jamais tu dis ça
parce que je suis noir et blanc c'est ça
regardez c'est un avion non c'est un
oiseau
non c'est super bizarre voilà monsieur
désiré autre chose ont l'option
reprendre les chiens
je compte gouttes
à
tu penses à ce que je pense ouais bon
j'suis désolé faut que je file je dis
attention
ce film est tiré d'une histoire vraie
inspiré de faits réels ce n'était pas la
première fois que patrick accouché d'un
tabouret en plastique
un soldat de la garde royale britannique
était venue spécialement de londres pour
nous jouer la marche turque en slip et
dessert tirait des lasers avec leur sexe
respectifs bref la vie suivait son cours
du régal